da kommt es Sahra Wagenknecht um Fragen
sagen die kann aus dem Stand 19 20
Prozent machen macht ihnen das Angst
nein sie wird wenn sie wirklich diesen
Weg geht den ich habe für falsch halte
aber wenn Sie glauben sie wird ihn gehen
ich befürchte es auch trotzdem werde ich
aber mit ihr reden und versuchen es ja
auszureden wenn sie den Weg geht wird
sie bei der Europawahl erfordert
erfolgreich sein vielleicht noch bei den
Landtagswahlen im Osten im nächsten Jahr
aber nach meiner festen Überzeugung bei
der Bundestagswahl 2025 nicht vor allen
Dingen darf sie die Mandate nicht
mitnehmen denn es ist ja für diese linke
und nicht für eine Partei und die Linke
Tod zu machen in dem Bundestag gewählt
war wahrscheinlich wird es trotzdem
machen aber ich werde versuchen es ja
auszureden dann habe ich diesen
bezüglich meine Schuldigkeit getan und
ich werde versuchen wir mit dir und
damit natürlich auch auf
dafür zu gewinnen dass wir dann um die
Linke kämpfen wenn Sie diesen Fehler
begehen daran darf sie nicht starten
[Musik]